I thought I went there to be kept safe
and I'd learn new ways to do to
self-harm I don't feel they made me any
better I think they made me a lot worse
Tyson Alice Amber you may remember some
of the young people who've spoken to Sky
News in recent months
over 50 former patients who've raised
serious allegations about the way they
were treated in mental health units run
by a single provider and paid for by the
NHS
they were now those involved in the care
of patients have spoken to Sky News
Callum is one of two former workers who
claim patient safety was compromised
because of inadequate Staffing and
training there was a lot of incidents
that could have been avoided
there were a lot of
patients who Maybe
cause significant harm to themselves
which could have been avoided had we had
more staff
Callum worked at this unit in maidenhead
in Berkshire run by the huntercom group
now part of Active Care Group a place
for young people who needed specialist
intervention for serious mental health
conditions and many of whom couldn't be
left alone
patients had a difficult time
gaining access to the Garden because
they required a staff member to go with
them and even using the toilet what did
you think about that when you had to
tell people no you can't go to the
toilet because we don't have a member of
staff to supervise you of course I felt
bad I felt horrendous Callum says his
last full shift was in February last
year after being given a warning for
taking an unauthorized break
he says staff weren't able to have
proper breaks he later resigned there
were a lot of staff there that really
did care obviously when we were below
numbers which was more often than not
that made it very challenging it made it
very difficult
former worker corroborated concerns
about patients being left at risk
because of Staff shortages
and Union official David McMullen told
us he's been representing staff at the
maidenhead unit for the last seven years
it always stood out as a problem
workplace when we compared it with other
Care Homes and similar employers there
was always more issues there but I think
over the last year that has massively
escalated
Active Care Group took over the hanticum
group in December 2021 a spokesperson
said these unconfirmed accusations
undermine the tremendous efforts being
made by current employees to support
those in their care at taplo Manor these
allegations have been made by two Junior
former members of Staff one of whom was
subject to disciplinary action neither
has worked at the hospital for a year
Staffing at taplo Manor is monitored
daily and the shifts are fully staffed
often with an additional two to three
workers on every shift as well as
therapists doctors teachers nurses and
Ward managers
previous owners Ellie Investments Group
said it regrets care services failed to
meet expected standards the latest
report from the regulator the Care
Quality commission published in August
2022 found taplo Manor had enough
nursing and support staff to keep
children and young people safe but the
hospital's overall safety rating was
inadequate a police investigation into
the death of a patient in February last
year is ongoing
this week the government announced a
rapid review into inpatient mental
health services in England Visa Holland
Sky News